Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schön guten Morgen Richard eine schönen
guten Morgen Markus geht's dir gut ja
mir geht's ganz gut ziemlich entspannte
Zeit ja entspannte Zeit findest du ja
eine politisch vielleicht nicht aber für
mich jetzt eine Zeit mit etwas weniger
Arbeit und das ist entspannt aber es
gibt so viele Dinge ne mit denen man
sich jetzt beschäftigen müsste und auch
muss geht dir das auch so ich habe so
viele Themen im Kopf haben so viele
unaufgeräumte Themen so ja
unordentlich zu Beginn ja zu Beginn des
Jahres es war eine Aufforderung ja ja
immer immer schwieriger ein fein
sortiertes Weltbild zu bekommen ja womit
beschäftigt gerade im Augenblick
beschäftige ich mich mit China okay ja
ich mache meine nächste Sendung über
China
mit frankieren ein ganz großartiger
toller Gast und ich habe gerade sein
Buch gelesen und gutes Buch es gibt
kennen das noch ich habe dermaßen viel
gelernt ja okay also das muss ich sagen
ich meine ich muss auch sagen ich hatte
über China sehr wenig Ahnung aber auch
nicht nur an Fakten eben viel gelernt
und viel gelernt über die chinesische
Wirtschaft und das Verhältnis zur
europäischen und amerikanischen ich habe
auch unglaublich viel darüber gelernt
was für ein merkwürdiges China Bild wie
Europäer eigentlich so haben
und wie sich die Welt aus der Sicht des
Chinesen darstellt und dass das
eigentlich nicht zusammenkommt
und das beschäftigt mich schon weil man
muss nicht so ein großer Prophet sein um
zu sagen dass das 21 jahrhundert
weitgehend dass chinesische jahrhunderts
sein wird es sieht jedenfalls ziemlich
viel danach aus und da richte ich mit
umzugehen das ist eine gigantische
Herausforderung und da kommen wir mit so
einfachen Schablonen mit dem wir China
sehr häufig begegnen auch nicht weiter
ja es ist wahr ich meine wir wir tun uns
so schwer mit dem Gedanken dass wir
nicht mehr das Sagen haben ne wir sind
nicht mehr der Mittelpunkt der Welt
jeder fünfte Erdenbewohner ist Chinese
ja und aus chinesischer Perspektive ist
Europa so was wie ein ziemlich
westliches anhängselasien
europäische macht mittlerweile ne mit
dem Aufkauf kritischer Infrastruktur mit
mit mit ganz vielen Kommunikationen beim
Hamburger Hafen demnächst mit drin
gehört weitgehend der Hafen von Piräus
den sie im Rekordtempo zum bedeutendsten
Hafen Europas ausbauen
sie machen Geschäfte sehr sehr viele in
Osteuropa sie haben große Geschäfte was
ich überhaupt nicht wusste in der
Ukraine gemacht genau ganz viele
Investitionen in der Ukraine
nicht dass die Russen den Krieg gewinnen
und möchten nicht dass der Westen den
Krieg so gewinnt dass die Ukraine quasi
ihm gehört
sondern sie wollen weiterhin ihr
Standbein in der Ukraine behalten das
sind alles Dinge die ich vorher nicht
gewusst ja auch Kasachstan zum Beispiel
wenn wenn Russland so eine geschlagene
macht irgendwann möglicherweise ist ein
eine ein schwacher Player sozusagen was
passiert da nicht Chinesen werden
irrsinnig davon profitieren wenn du
heute wenn du mit Kasachen sprichst
erzähl dir das wie das läuft also wie
unglaublich viele chinesische
Restaurants Geschäfte in almati und
anderswo mittlerweile da sind also das
heißt man man übernimmt die schlicht
untergreifend bitte wirtschaftlicher
Power ja so wie die Europäer das die
letzten 200 Jahre überall in der Welt
gemacht haben und jetzt machen die
Chinesen das gleiche was wir immer
gemacht haben
und da ist nicht so einfach mit
umzugehen also ich glaube wenn man so
200 Jahre lang das Gefühl hat man war
der Mittelpunkt der Welt wenn das auch
nie gestimmt hat aber man war es halt
Kraft militärischer und vor allen Dingen
wirtschaftlicher Stärke und jetzt eben
sieht dass sich da ganz ganz viel
verändert und dass die die immer draußen
vor der Tür standen jetzt auch mitten im
Raum sind ich glaube das ist ein
gigantischer und auch sehr schwerer
Umdenkungsprozess für unser
Selbstverständnis
ja die dieses also was du da gerade
thematisierst Richard und führt
eigentlich direkt auch zu dem Thema aber
dass ich heute mit dir reden wollte
nämlich über das was da an Silvester
passiert ist dieses Unbehagen ne mit
hast das hast du irgendwie offenbar mit
Blick auf China auch ja und Unbehagen
ach ja ich will nicht sagen dass ich im
Blick auf China also ich kann ja schon
den Gedanken nachvollziehen dass ich
sage jetzt mal so lange die Amerikaner
und die Europäer dran also die Europäer
seit 200 Jahren und die Amerikaner
Seiten Zweiten Weltkrieg und warum
sollte denn erheblicher Anteil der
Menschen in dieser Welt die meisten
Menschen leben ja in Asien warum sollen
die von den den Segnungen ausgeschlossen
sein und warum sollen die nicht auch mit
über die Geschichte der Welt bestimmen
also diesen Gedanken kann ich unter
gerechtigkeitstheoretischen
Gesichtspunkten völlig nachvollziehen
aber ich glaube dass es diese dieser
Verlust ist Selbstverständnis sind ja
auch stolz auf die Aufklärung auf unsere
Werte und so weiter und jetzt sind wir
mit anderen Wertesystem konfrontiert und
dieser Umgang damit dass das immer so
ein Unbehagen ist bei der Vorstellung
dass irgendwann China vielleicht die
Spielregeln in der Welt angeht da ist
ein gewisses Unbehagen ist auf jeden
Fall
so und jetzt harte Überleitung Silvester
Richard wie hast du das wahrgenommen
wird mich wirklich interessieren also
speziell Berlin aber auch andere Städte
reden wir gleich noch im Einzelnen
darüber sie allein dieses Szenen also
diese Einsatzwagen ja drin mit besetzt
mit freiwilligen Feuerwehrleuten ja
freiwillig das müssen wir noch mal
unterstreichen das sind Menschen die
machen das weil es ihnen offensichtlich
ein anliegendes anderen Leuten zu helfen
die werden dafür nicht mal bezahlt
werden bei so einer Barriere ganz
großartig dass es solche Menschen noch
gibt genau und die fragen mich wie lange
tun die sich das noch an werden an so
einer Barrikade so brutal angegriffen
dass sie um ihr Leben fürchten ich habe
den Einsatzbericht eines anderen eines
Polizeibeamten gelesen der sich
versteckt auch interessant übrigens in
einem Döner Imbiss dann weil er merkt
okay wir haben keine Chance gegen die
und und der der
Imbissbesitzer erzählt dieser Polizist
hat vor meinen Augen gebrannt der hat so
ein Böller direkt hinter seine
Schutzweste bekommt der hat gebrannt und
dann versuchen die dort also der die
sozusagen über die nicht so viel
diskutiert wird weil plötzlich haben
wieder einen migrationdebatte der
Migrant hilft dem möglicherweise auch
migrantischen Polizisten ja dabei dieses
Feuer zu löschen und der beschreibt
diese Situation wir haben irgendwie
kaltes Wasser genommen und haben
versucht irgendwie diese brennende Haut
in irgendeiner Form zu kühlen das musst
du dir vorstellen da wird ein Bus
abgefackelt der wird in ein Polizeiauto
geschossen
1700 Einsätze Liste allein die Berliner
Feuerwehr auf 38 Übergriffe auf ihre
Leute 15 davon verletzt die Zahl der
verletzten Polizisten noch viel viel
höher und ich sag mal so es gibt kein
Problem dass man lösen könnte ohne es
auszusprechen in Deutschland leben
offenbar einige Menschen die jeden
Respekt vor diesem System verloren haben
falls Sie ihn je hatten so hat es hat
einen Kasim dieser Tage ausgedrückt und
das jetzt und das finde ich ist die neue
Qualität die das erschreckend
unerschrocken zeigen
also ich stimme dir bei allem was du
gesagt hast zu auf sowohl bei der
Betroffenheit
wie bei der Ungeheuerlichkeit wie viele
Menschen es gibt die darüber müssen wir
ja über die Motive müssen wir noch
länger versuchen nachzudenken hier ohne
mit der Wimper zu zucken ganz
offensichtlich oder mit viel Spaß dabei
ja Straftaten gegen Unschuldige gegen
Helfer und so weiter
Begehen der einzige Punkt wo ich nicht
so sicher bin dass du recht hast ist
dass das neu ist
also ich bin ja ein bisschen älter als
du und ich kann mich daran erinnern 1983
ja da ging in der Nachbarstadt Wuppertal
ich komme ja aus Solingen etwas los was
nachher über 20 Jahre die Republik
beschäftigt hat und das waren die Chaos
Tage ja bei den Chaostagen trafen sich
die Punks es gab sogar mal
internationale Chaos Tage einzig und
allein zu dem Zweck Randale gegen die
Polizei zu machen
und die fanden dann nur die erste Zeit
in Wuppertal statt und dann fanden die
weil es dann konkreten anders für Gabi
in Hannover statt und dann gab es
manchmal Tage lange Ausschreitungen
brutalste Art zwischen Punks und Polizei
ohne das ist dafür jetzt irgendein Ernst
zu leben der Anlass gegeben hätte der
irgendwie Gewaltexzesse rechtfertigt
einfach auch aus Spaß an der Hand genau
und das hatte noch ein viel größeres
Ausmaß als das was jetzt hier in Berlin
passiert ist ohne dass wir harmlosen zu
wollen also ich glaube
das überwiegend jüngere Menschen und
überwiegend Männer ja im großen Spaß
daran haben rücksichtslos brutal und so
weiter gegen den Staat gegen die
Ordnungsmacht gegen Polizisten
vorzugehen das ist leider leider nicht
neu
ich habe auch eben bewusst gesagt die
Dimension ich habe also es stimmt was du
sagst die die Neuköllner
Integrationsbeauftragte Günter glaube
ich im Spiegel irgendwo gesagt da gibt's
so ein simplen Reflex der im Grunde
dahinter steht und der Reflex ist die
sind vom Staat und wir sind gegen die ja
und diese Tendenz sagt sie gibt's in
allen Großstädten das würde das
untermauern was du sagst über Hamburg
z.B in dem Zusammenhang muss man auch
mal sprechen und immer in diesen
abgehängten Milieus und Rücksicht aus es
gibt sagt sie ist zwar nicht interessant
Subkulturen der gescheiterten
ja was ihr Recht gibt ist wenn du zum
Beispiel auch jetzt mit Blick auf dieses
Jahr Silvester wird mir das wirklich mal
genauer angeguckt schaust das gab es
eigentlich in in vielen Orten das gab es
auch in Ostdeutschland ja das gab es in
Jahnsdorf im Erzgebirge das gab es in
Thüringen in Schmölln da haben sie in
einen Telefon ein Toilettenhäuschen in
die Luft gesprengt in in Saalfeld an der
Saale wurden 40 Autos beschädigt in
Erfurt Schaden von 300 000 €, dann Borna
sächsische Kreisstadt haben sich 200
Leute versammelt und haben versucht da
den den Weihnachtsbaum auf dem
Marktplatz in Brand zu stecken und haben
sogar die stützkeile her am
an diesem Baum entfernt damit ergibt
oder unfällt das ist völlig irre das ist
geisteskrank und wenn Du Dir mal
anschaust Leipzig
Connewitz ne die linksextremistischen
Ausschreitungen zu Silvester immer
mittlerweile fast schon eine ist ja
schon ein trauriges Ritual in G wurden
auch in dieser Silvesternacht Polizisten
brutal attackiert das heißt da gibt es
tatsächlich offenbar so eine Subkultur
der gescheiterten ja und die und diese
Gewalt und das ist interessant ist
männlich ja zum zum allergrößten Teil ja
und ich frage mich die ganze Zeit bevor
wir auch noch mal vielleicht genauer
reingehen woher kommt das woher kommt
die Wut ohnmächtig Verdacht fühlen sich
für eine Nacht mächtig und Leute die
keinen Grund haben besonders stolz auf
sich zu sein inszenieren etwas worauf
sie voreinander und vor sich selbst
stolz sind
es gibt eine Lust an der Gewalt es gibt
eine richtige ich meine Lust an der
Gewalt ist etwas das gibt es quer durch
die ganze Gesellschaft denn sonst würden
nicht jeden Abend 1000 Tote eröffnen im
deutschen matscheiben sterben dann wären
nicht Gewalt in in Kinofilm heute viel
brutaler als das vor 50 Jahren war also
diese Lust an der gewaltige existiert
aber jemand der ein der ein gutes Leben
hat und viel zu verlieren hat der
überlegt sich dreimal ob er irgendwo in
irgendeiner Form auch nur ansatzweise
gewalttätig wird der hat eine sehr hohe
Hemmschwelle im Regelfall jedenfalls
nicht jeder aber die meisten wenn du
aber nichts zu verlieren hast wenn es
also keinen Grund gibt das was das
Bürgertum anständig nennt zu sein
dann ziehst du deinen Stolz genau
umgekehrt daraus das sind nicht dazu
gehörst und das du für eine kurze Zeit
so diese Allmacht oder sie sind Potenz
Fantasie in dem Moment ne wir haben die
zurückgeschlagen wir haben der Polizei
Angst gemacht die haben Angst vor uns
gemacht und dann trommelt man sich wegen
Gorilla auf die Brust und fühlt sich
großartig und ich glaube das ist
sozusagen der Kick da dran und
interessanterweise die Deutschen haben
ja eine interessante Gewaltgeschichte
was so Silvester anbelangt im Silvester
lässt man ja sowieso die Sau raus ne und
und die die einen auf die harmlose Art
und Weise und diejenigen die Spaß in der
Gewalt haben und nichts zu verlieren
haben eben auf eine härtere Art und
Weise alles das was ich jetzt hier mache
sind keine Entschuldigung ja das sind
nur versuchen keiner Erklärung was dahin
in den Köpfen sich mutmaßlich abspielt
also man weiß das ja von sich selbst
auch noch dass man so in der Zeit so
20-21 oder so
launiger oder fahrlässiger mit Dingen
umgegangen ist
und bei manchen Menschen bei den Gewalt
das Lebensthema in dieser Hinsicht ist
ist das genau dasselbe man macht sich da
keinen Kopf und keine Gedanken man ist
da gefühlskalt gegenüber dem Polizisten
der da halb in Brand gesteckt worden ist
und so weiter also das ist einerseits
natürlich Verrohrung aber es ist auf der
anderen Seite auch so ein Jux ja der
keine Empathie kennt
also es wird selber als juxempfunden die
finden das lustig in dem Moment wo sie
das machen meinst du ja ich glaube ja
ich glaube die ich meine ich habe hier
diese Bilder im Fernsehen gesehen von
all diejenigen die sich ja noch
gebürstet haben damit und so weiter vor
Kameras und so ja und das ist dann so
ein Rausch der hält dann ein zwei Tage
an und dann ist auch wieder weg was der
ganz interessant ist
Jugendkriminalität Gewalt geht der
statistisch zurück ne ja das ist
interessant es geht ja auch insgesamt
oder Alkoholismus in der Jugend zum
Beispiel zurück ich glaube auch immer es
gibt eine Korrelation wie viel Kinder
werden von ihren Eltern Fragen und wie
hoch ist Jugendgewalt ich glaube da gibt
es einen direkten zusammen ja also
dadurch dass Kinder heute nicht mehr
geschlagen werden also viele nicht mehr
und dass sie weitgehend gewaltfrei in
der Praxis aufwachsen das hat eben zur
Folge dass sie im Regelfall auch weniger
gewalttätig sind also wenn ich meinen
Schulweg in den 70er Jahren entlang
gegangen bin dann war es selbst in der
Stadt wie Solingen gab es immer so ein
gewisses Potenzial ja an Leuten wo man
aufpassen musste dass sie eigentlich
aufmisten auf dem Hause weg so jetzt
gibt es natürlich in Deutschland immer
noch genug Stadtteile da ist das
wahrscheinlich auch heute noch so es ist
aber in Solingen nicht mehr so und ist
auch ein sehr vielen anderen Orten fast
nicht mehr so das heißt also so diese
alltägliche Gewalt die ist weniger
geworden ich habe in Köln in der
türkischer Straße gewohnt in den 80er
Jahren Ende der 80er Jahre Anfang der
90er Jahre also wie oft ist es gewesen
wenn man nachts um 12 oder Mainz über
die Straße ging das da Leute mit
Bierflaschen geworfen haben oder ein
angepöbelt haben und so weiter das ist
auch heute nicht irgendwie lustigste
Straße in Köln auf seinem Karneval und
da ist ein besonders gewalttätig
übrigens aber das ist insgesamt nicht
mehr geworden das ist tendenziell eher
weniger geworden aber weißt du was ich
verändert hat die Erwartungshaltung hat
sich verändert früher gehörte so ein
gewisses Potenzial an Gewalt zu dem was
man leider in Kauf nehmen musste und
heute denkt man sich wie kann es sowas
geben
das heißt also die
Selbstverständlichkeit von Gewalt und
das ist eine gute Entwicklung die ist
geringer geworden und trotzdem hat
Deutschland jetzt und das ist das was
gerade ja auch so die Gemüter hochkochen
lässt Deutschland hat jetzt plötzlich
mal wieder eine Migrationsdebatte also
jetzt gerade gesagt 33 verletzt der
Einsatzkräfte allein in Berlin 145 Täter
tendenziell jung männlich 45 von ihm mit
deutscher Staatsangehörigkeit ein
Drittel Syrer und Afghanen Kopf
gesprochen ja aber das musst Du zwei
Zahlen auseinanderhalten das ist glaube
ich für die Debatte ganz ganz wichtig
also die Tagesschau hat sogar von 57
Festnahmen in der Silvesternacht wegen
irgendwelcher Form von Gewaltdelikten
gemeldet
aber das wovon wir vorhin geredet haben
diese gezielten Angriffe auf die
Rettungskräfte
dieser Aktion war an der Zahl von ich
glaube 38
und bei diesen 38 die diese
Rettungskräfte angegriffen haben da
waren zwei Drittel deutsche
so dass man die beiden Zahlen
auseinanderhalten muss also die erste
Zahl besagt da ist der Migration
Migrantenanteil sehr hoch ja es hat sehr
viele gewaltige breite gewalttätige
Migranten in der Silvesternacht gegeben
richtig aber bei diesem Beispiel was du
vorhin gesagt hast da waren die
Deutschen in der Mehrheit also Menschen
mit deutschen Pass meinst du
heißt offiziell zwei Drittel waren
Deutsche unter 21 Jahren okay und das
ist jetzt genau mein Punkt ich ich habe
tatsächlich
ehrlich gesagt ein Loch wie größeres
Unbehagen als mit dem was da passiert
ist was wirklich schlimm genug ist und
ich will es in keinster Weise
relativieren aber mindestens ebenso
großes Unbehagen habe ich persönlich mit
der Reaktion unsere Staates auf das was
da passiert ist also jetzt fangen wir an
diese Statistiken ganz genau mal ins 38
dann 33 dann 45 dann haben so und so
viele in deutschen Pass dann sind aber
deutsche mit einem Migrationshintergrund
dann sind es Ausländer Syrer Afghanen
und so weiter jetzt fangen wir an
sozusagen dieses dieses Zahlenspiel zu
spielen und ich habe immer das Gefühl
das macht die Leute wahnsinnig wütend
und mich verstört das auch weil ich
denke ist das doch nicht unser ernst
dass wir diese Debatte jetzt sozusagen
anhand von fünf Zahlen führen
wirklich auf das grundsätzliche Bild zu
gucken und ich sage jetzt mal ein Aspekt
der Geschichte von dem ich glaube dass
er die Menschen wirklich umtreibt
nämlich die Frage was war eigentlich die
Reaktion des Staates auf das was da
passiert ist also nach meinem
Kenntnisstand war der allergrößte Teil
dieser 145 die da festgenommen worden
sind am nächsten Tag wieder raus
und das ist genau das was glaube ich die
Leute zunehmend nicht mehr verstehen
sagen pass auf jetzt müssen wir noch mal
sagen ja also 145 bei den bei bei Hund
über 100 davon wissen wir nicht was sie
gemacht haben ja die waren jetzt nicht
an dieser Aktion über die wir uns hier
völlig zurecht riesig aufregen waren die
ja nicht beteiligt so jetzt weiß ich
nicht warum die hochgenommen wurden was
die gemacht haben das müsste man im
Einzelnen gucken und dann weiß man auch
nicht was passiert Personalien
aufgenommen und die Frage wer wird da
noch weiter strafrechtlich verfolgt oder
nicht die spannende Frage ist für mich
ist dieser Kern also was passiert mit
diesen 38 Personen die ja da die diese
freiwilligen Rettungskräfte in den
Hinterhalt gelockt haben
das ist die spannende Sache und da ist
es natürlich völlig klar ein Staat der
der nicht in der Lage ist
seine Gesetzes macht die ja da ist man
muss ja gar nicht die Strafen
verschaffen es geht ja im Zweifelsfall
immer darum dass man das strafpotenzial
gibt und dass man es anwendet ja genau
deswegen ist das immer so billig zu
sagen wie Söder oder sonst die Straßen
verschärfen das sagt man dann immer in
so einer Situation
dieser Tage ist die mit der ganzen Härte
des Gesetzes da werde ich immer sauer
aber ich denke was sollte
immer nur ein Viertel genau eingesetzt
wird genau das ist übrigens tatsächlich
wahrscheinlich sehr oft so das ist alles
also der andere kriegt eine Anleitung
braucht wahnsinnig viele Leute die sich
damit beschäftigen und so und da
passiert natürlich glaube ich und das
ist jedenfalls ich bin ja jetzt kein
Justizbeamter aber das dann sehr häufig
die Dinge im Zweifelsfall er Lachs
angegangen werden das könnte durchaus
sein
und hier ist dann einfach die Forderung
dass das jetzt nicht passiert
ja aber schwierig oder also das ist das
wo Leute das Gefühl haben da
funktioniert der Staat einfach nicht
mehr ja und umgekehrt diejenigen die
Randale machen ja denken der Staat ist
kein ernstzunehmender Gegner genau also
meine vor dem muss man keinen Respekt
haben der kann sich sowieso nicht
richtig so und jetzt und jetzt mal die
Zahlen dazu also Friedrich-Ebert
Stiftung Untersuchung also es gibt viele
Studien zu dem Thema aber die jüngste
53% der deutschen also über die Hälfte
ist unzufrieden mit dem Funktionieren
dieser Demokratie und wenn man die Leute
fragt ob sie das Gefühl haben Politiker
kümmern sich um die Sorgen von Menschen
wie Ihnen dann sagen Achtung dreiviertel
ja 75% fast sagen nein das heißt ein
Drittel
traut noch der Justiz oder der Politik
und der ganze Rest sagt nee weißt du was
auf die kann ich mich nicht verlassen
wenn ich die brauche sind die schlicht
und ergreifen entweder nicht da oder sie
sind hilflos und über die dies betrifft
haben jetzt noch gar nicht gesprochen
wenn du Gespräche führst macht das
manchmal so mit Streifen Polizisten die
so treffen beim Joggen oder so wenn du
mit diesen Leuten sprichst die da ihren
Rücken hinhalten die teilweise
abgefackelt und angegriffen relativ
wenig Geld das muss man dazu haben einen
Frust das ist unvorstellbar und man hat
das Gefühl es ist jetzt wenigstens schon
mal ein ein Fortschritt dass man einfach
mal klar benennt wer diese Leute sind
und auch nicht versucht zu verwässern
das ist das Thema überhaupt gibt und
sagt nein immer und ist ein ist ja kein
neues Phänomen doch in der Qualität
finde ich ist es ein absolut neues
Phänomen aber noch bei Markus es ist
doch egal ob das Phänomen neu ist ich
glaube die Qualität der Gewalt war
vorher schon da aber es kann doch sein
dass ihr sagen wir sind da früher zu
Lachs mit umgegangen und egal ob neu
oder nicht neu das lassen wir uns in
dieser Form nicht mehr gefallen das
würde ich ja bereits ausreichen also da
musst du nicht in die Beweislast treten
dass das neu ist ja weil also
Jugendkrawalle und und auch massive
Gewalt gegen Polizei ist so alt wie die
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
also rein statistisch ist es ja
offensichtlich so gewesen dass die die
meisten Gewaltdelikte durch Jugendlichen
in den späten 50er Jahren waren was ich
heute kaum einer vorstellen kann da muss
man schon noch hier den alten Buchholz
Film der Halbstarken vor Augen haben und
damals war die die Gewalt also eine
einer nachkriegsjugend die die harte
Zeit nach dem Krieg und auch diese diese
ordnungslosigkeit der späten 40er Jahre
erlebt hatte da hat es ja erstmal sehr
viel mehr Armut gegeben und auch sehr
viel mehr Verrohung und da gab es auch
brutalste Auseinandersetzungen also
deswegen geht's mir eigentlich nicht
darum ob das Phänomen neu ist sondern
wir können einfach sagen wir wollen uns
das in der heutigen Zeit auf die
bisherige Art und Weise nicht mehr
mieten lassen das kann man ja ganz klar
sagen ohne dass das deswegen neu sein
muss so und die die die Debatte die da
natürlich auch entsteht ist und das ist
das was mir immer auffällt bei solchen
Diskussionen in Deutschland
also was festzustellen ist und ich ich
bin froh darüber dass wir endlich mal
erwachsen genug und in der Lage dazu
sind dass dann auch einfach mal
auszusprechen zu sagen ein großer Teil
derer die dort
involviert waren sind junge Männer mit
Migrationshintergrund die ganz
offensichtlich diesen deutschen Staat
verachten die weiß schon während ich das
sage schreiben jetzt schon wieder die
ersten und sagen ich seinen Rassist und
was mir immer wieder auffällt ist es
wird dann sozusagen von der
konservativen Seite wird das Thema dann
gekapert und dann nimmt man das und
schreit dann auf unser kuck mal wir
haben es doch immer gewusst und diese
diese diese ganze linksliberale
Einwanderungspolitik das geht so nicht
weiter und von der anderen Seite kommt
immer wieder dieses dröhnende schweigen
weil sozusagen nicht sein darf
ja also ich meine beide Seiten machen
sich so leicht also die Linken machen es
sich zu leicht weil sie grundsätzlich
Angst davor haben in irgendeiner Form
etwas zu sagen was ihnen als rassistisch
ausgelegt werden kann und da ist die
Spanne wo das anfängt sehr groß außerdem
müsste man sich dann verfehlte
Integrationspolitik vorwerfen lassen was
deswegen immer ein bisschen komisch ist
als das ist ja nicht so ist als ob die
Linken immer alleine dieses Land regiert
hätten also die ganze Migration und
Integrationspolitik der letzten 50 Jahre
haben die Konservativen mindestens
genauso zu verantworten wie die Linken
da gibt's ja gar keinen Unterschied aber
immer wenn die dickste passieren wird
die Linken in die Schule geschoben und
die Linken trauen sich eben auch nicht
klare Kante zur zeigen und Straftäter
dann zu benennen und sagen das waren
warum ist das so schwer Richard sag mir
das mal aber warum ist es so dass
Menschenbild der Linken irgendwo
widerspricht aber das kann doch nicht
sein man muss doch in der Lage sein
Dinge klar auszusprechen es kann doch
nicht sein dass wir nicht in der Lage
sind klar zu thematisieren
geht dass das ist doch genau das
sozusagen was dann dazu führt dass man
Leuten von der AFD und anderen dann den
Diskurs überlässt das geht also in der
richtig ganz alten klassisch linken
Debatte ja die ich ja noch relativ gut
aus meiner Jugend und so weiter kenne da
ist das natürlich so dass alles Böse in
der Welt kommt vom Kapitalismus ja und
die Menschen werden nur gegeneinander
aufgehetzt und eigentlich sind sie alle
gut und lieb und wollen den Frieden
miteinander klarkommen und wenn es
Ausländerfeindlichkeit gibt dann ist es
weil sozusagen das Böse kapitalistische
System den Arbeiter auf seinen Kollegen
hätte der anders aussieht als er das ist
sozusagen die Grundierung dieser
Moralvorstellung
dass sozusagen jedes anprangern von
Fehlverhalten ausländischer Mitbürger
einfach nur im Dienste der herrschenden
ist so das ist sozusagen das ganz alte
klassische linke Bild
und aus dem hat sie sich nie so weit
befreit dass sie zu differenzierteren
urteilen gekommen ist
und bei den Konservativen die ja selber
für wie gesagt für die migrations- und
Integrationspolitik der letzten
Jahrzehnte verantwortlich sind ist es
immer noch dieses alte Unbehagen aus der
Adenauer Zeit das anfing als die ersten
Italiener kamen und als
spaghetti-fresser beschimpft wurden und
die ersten Türken kamen und nicht
integriert werden sollten in die
Gesellschaft weil man ja wollte dass die
Wände als Arbeitskräfte Problem gelöst
ist möglich weil wir nach Hause fahren
also wir haben sozusagen auf beiden
Seiten haben wir eine ganz alte
emotionale und strukturelle Wurzel
verstehe ich und die treffen dann immer
so aufeinander als würde man nicht in
Wahrheit gemeinsam miteinander für all
die politischen Dinge verantwortlich
sein die wir heute leben aber noch mal
man muss es doch kritisieren können wenn
sich jemand daneben benimmt und zwar
ganz unabhängig von der Herkunft ich bin
auf deiner Seite das tut die Linken aber
nicht das kommt da nicht
ja ich weiß dass das so ist ich habe es
ja gerade versucht zu erklären warum das
so ist ich habe ja nicht gesagt dass ich
die Sichtweise teile ich fühle mich
einfach nur zu erklären wo sie herkommt
aber aber das ist natürlich ein ein Teil
dieser ein Teil davon sind diese Umfrage
ergeben dass sie die ich gerade zitiert
habe was die Leute sagen weißt du was
man kann den eh nicht glauben man kann
den nicht trauen man kann diesen
Statistiken nicht trauen die reden sich
das jetzt wieder zurecht und so weiter
man kann sofort das Gefühl in dem Moment
wo du irgendetwas sagst kommt sofort die
Rassismuskeule und dann ist die Debatte
vorbei
ja also es ist doch man kann das doch
ganz nüchtern und logisch betrachten und
kann sagen die sogenannten abgehängten
Schichten in der Gesellschaft wer gehört
dazu
und da muss man einfach sagen war früher
die Anzahl der deutschen größer und
heute ist die Anzahl derjenigen mit
Migrationshintergrund die zu den
sogenannten abgehängten Schichten
gehören deutlich größer und deswegen ist
es auch nicht verwunderlich dass wenn
solche Randale Aktionen passieren oder
Gewalttaten oder sowas ist häufiger
überproportional hohen Bestandteil von
Migranten dabei gibt das ist auch eine
ganz logische Erklärung dafür dann muss
ich das nicht erklären aus irgendeinem
Naturell oder sagen der Ausländer ist so
oder der Migrant ist so sondern kann ich
ganz einfach sagen guck dir die
Lebensumstände an in denen die Leute die
Krawall machen Leben und dann guck dir
an wie viele Deutsche leben unter
solchen Lebensumständen und wie viele
Leute mit Migrationshintergrund
und das wiederum muss sehr sorgfältig
abgegrenzt werden davon dass man gucken
wie viele Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund haben sich
hervorragend und friedlich in diese
Gesellschaft integriert was ja der sehr
viel größere Teil ist definitiv und das
nimmt natürlich dann solchen Menschen
wie afd-politiker den Wind aus den
Segeln die versuchen eine soziale Frage
zu ethnisieren ja was interessant ist
ist dass es viele Migranten ich habe
gerade heute morgen mit einer Muslima
die ich gut kenne länger darüber
gesprochen die sind entsetzt darüber
sind absolut entsetzt darüber wie sich
diese Typen Benehmen das kann doch nicht
sein und die zweite Frage ist immer
warum lässt sich der deutsche Staat das
gefallen warum lasst ihr euch das
gefallen weil er Personalmangel hat
würde ich mal als allererstes sagen weil
Polizisten heute anders sozialisiert
sind als Polizisten vor 50 Jahren
also weil Polizisten heute
ebenfalls weniger Gewalt anwenden können
als sie das früher waren in einer
Gesellschaft die Gewalt Anwendung
grundsätzlich sehr sehr viel skeptischer
sieht auch von Seiten der Staatsmacht
als früher das heißt also die Polizei
darf nicht mehr so wie sie früher mal
durfte
großer Unterschied deutsche Polizei ist
nicht amerikanische Polizei das hat auch
seine Vorteile wie wir wissen und dann
ist die personell wahnsinnig unter
besetzt genauso wie Justiz wahnsinnig
unter besetzt ist weil der einem der
reichsten Länder der Welt für all diese
Dinge kein Geld da ist und weil sich ja
egal wer regiert egal ob konservative
und Sozialdemokraten grüne und so weiter
daran offensichtlich nie irgendwas
ändert weil dieses Problem haben wir nun
schon seit mindestens zwei Jahrzehnten
wenn ich noch länger ja also ist auch
ganz interessant irgendwie wie Leute wie
ähm z.B Herbert Roll CDU Innenminister
in NRW der seit Jahren sehr
erfolgreich würde ich sagen gegen Clan
Kriminalität vorgeht der sagt das ist
nicht nur ein Migrationsproblem sondern
da reden wir eigentlich sagte seraphyla
dieser Tage auch da geht es weniger um
misslungene Integration da geht es
eigentlich um Sozialisation die das
schief gelaufen ist das ist der
entscheidende Satz also tatsächlich ist
das Hauptproblem misslungene
Sozialisation Menschen die keine
Schulabschlüsse machen ich meine das ist
ja auch ein Thema was wir für sehr viel
diskutiert haben es ist natürlich müsste
jedes Kind das in Deutschland eine
Grundschule besucht Deutsch können
auch im völlig im eigenen Interesse also
wenn ich schon im Kindergarten abgehängt
bin weil ich meine Deutschkenntnisse
nicht ausreichen wenn ich schon ins
erste Schuljahr eingeschult werde und
kaum Deutsch kann dann habe ich von sehr
wenigen meistens Mädchen abgesehen
eigentlich keine richtige Chance nachher
den Weg zu gehen den ich mir vorgenommen
habe oder der zu einer gelungenen
Integration führt und wir schaffen das
doch noch bis heute nicht dass jedes
Kind mit Migration ins Hintergrund im
Kindergarten vernünftig Deutschland ich
meine das schaffen wir was ja schon mal
eine ganz ganz wichtige Grundlage wäre
auch dafür ist in diesem reichen Land
kein Geld da aber mir greift das zu kurz
Richard weißt du was da mitschwingt ist
immer genau dieser Sound der Staat
liefert da nicht an dem Punkt wie ist
das zu einfach die Muslime die ich
gerade zitiert habe die sagte heute
morgen zu mir pass auf über Hamburg wird
gar nicht geredet Silvester da gab es
auch meine Kinder waren draußen und es
war furchtbar
ja lebt hier in Hamburg ihre Kinder sind
hier geboren die sagt das war furchtbar
und ich sagte wer war das denn und sie
sagt zu mir Markus das waren alles
Ausländer es waren alles unsere Leute
ein zwei Prozent deutsche und ich
verstehe nicht warum sie sich hier so
benehmen
ich habe ja versucht wohin ein paar
Begründungen dafür zu geben die Frage
richard ist ja ja ich verstehe dass
dieses man man hat nicht das Gefühl
Teilen dieser Gesellschaft zu sein das
ist in sicherlich in Teilen auch das
Ergebnis einer
Philosophen ja genau genau was was ich
damals auch immer wieder gehört habe und
das läuft jetzt mir z.B ist als Argument
völlig ein wenn du aus so einer
patreonischen Welt kommst in Afghanistan
oder Syrien ja wo der Mann das Sagen hat
dann kommst du in dieses Land und
erlebst dich selber plötzlich als total
schwach der Typ der gerade eben noch zu
Hause
war genau dem dem Frauen zu Diensten zu
sein haben und so weiter der liebt sich
plötzlich selber nicht total befindet
sich als entwertet und er lebt dann dass
seine kleine Schwester sich die
Unverschämtheit erlaubt ja an der Schule
am Gymnasium ihren Weg gehen vielleicht
sogar Karriere zu machen erfolgreich zu
sein der fühlt sich entwertet aber es
tut mir leid wenn du in diesem Land
nicht in der Lage bist zu verstehen
welche gigantischen Chancen du in diesem
Land hast und deine einzige Antwort
darauf ist dann mit Gewalt zu reagieren
und Böller auf Polizisten zu schießen
oder mit Schreckschusspistolen
nein aber Achtung hast du das ganze Jahr
ja die Verachtung hast das ist ja eine
Lebenshaltung und ich habe letzte Nacht
lange in dem in dem kommenden Buch von
Hamed Update Zermatt gelesen den ich
sehr schätze ja schlauer Mann der unter
Polizeischutz lebt wie du weißt weil er
immer wieder auch über den Islam spricht
und so weiter und den man und ich habe
ihn dann angeschrieben und habe ihm
gratuliert zu diesem wirklich guten Buch
das kommt jetzt in diesen Tagen und der
sagte in einem Interview dieser Tage das
Problem sind diese jungen Männer die
diesen deutschen Staat verachten und er
glaubt dass die Ereignisse in Berlin die
Spitze des Eisberges sind er sagt der
schlummert noch ein ganz anderes Wut
Potenzial wir haben einen
grundsätzliches Problem da gibt es eine
einen einen Hass gegen gegen dieses Land
und der wird sozusagen immer weiter
angefeuert und er sagt das hat auch
tatsächlich mit einem falschen Islam
Verständnis zu tun
und ich fand das deswegen bemerkenswert
weil das von ihm kommt wie man es
Ägypter und ich persönlich bin jemand
viele viele Muslime getroffen
im Laufe von Dreharbeiten auch in
Deutschland immer wieder und ich mag die
weil ich Leute die ein klares
Wertesystem haben prinzipiell mag
deswegen mag ich auch Christen wenn sie
nicht wundermentalistisch werden und ich
mag eben genauso Muslime wenn sie nicht
fundamentalistisch werden aber er sagt
eben wir haben in Teilen die Kontrolle
abgegeben über das was zum Beispiel in
deutschen Koranschulen gelehrt wird und
du findest darin eine Zahl die hat mich
hat mich wirklich weil ich plötzlich
hellwache als ich das gelesen habe
schätze mal wie viele Koran Schulen gibt
es hier in Deutschland ich habe nicht
die geringste Ahnung
okay und ungefähr die Hälfte der hier
lebenden muslimischen Schüler besucht
neben dem normalen Schulunterricht auch
diese Koran Schulen okay jetzt verstehe
ich nicht viel von Koran Schulen was
lernt man da das ist genau sein Thema er
sagt der wird von Islamverbänden
geleitet die sich weitgehend staatlicher
Kontrolle unterziehen und diese
Indoktrinierung trägt natürlich auch
Früchte und er sagt deswegen nimmt
religiöses Mobbing an Schulen zu daher
kommt auch diese Verachtung für alles
westliche da kommt doch die Verachtung
für diesen Staat und richtig bitter wird
finde ich wenn du weißt und das finde
ich sehr interessant und das passt total
zu dem was ich auch so erlebe im Alltag
ich habe dir gerade beschrieben wie ich
Muslima und und und Muslime wie ich die
wahrnehme ja im Alltag
freundliche nette zuvorkommende Menschen
gerade mal 15 Prozent der hier lebenden
Muslime in diesem Land sind überhaupt
organisiert in diesen Islamverbänden ich
hatte das heißt das werden noch weniger
ja so das heißt wenn die auftreten wenn
die von der türkischen Religionsbehörde
gesteuert werden und so weiter wenn die
in der Öffentlichkeit sprechen dann
sprechen die nicht für den Großteil der
richtig Muslime aber die Wahrnehmung ist
natürlich eine völlig andere und das
diskreditiert sozusagen alle anderen die
mit dem was da passiert ist mit dieser
Verachtung für den Staaten nichts zu tun
haben das ist bitte könnten die anderen
Länder dagegen tun naja also ich glaube
die bräuchten erstmal eine Stimme ich
glaube wir reden teilweise mit den
völlig waschen Leuten ich glaube wir
hören diesen Leuten viel zu viel zu ich
glaube wir müssen die die Kontrolle über
diese über diese Koran Schulen und über
das was da sonst passiert wir müssen
dringend die Kontrolle darüber
zurückgewinnen und wir müssen all den
friedfertigen und und und gut
integrierten Menschen in diesem Land und
das ist ja wirklich der Großteil ich
meine das Bittere ist ja das Bittere ist
doch das ist jetzt wieder so wird als
wäre die Integrationsgeschichte in
Deutschland eine Geschichte des
Scheiterns das ist sie aber in Wahrheit
nicht eigentlich müssen wir ja sagen
guck mal bei dem Polizeibericht dann von
dem wir ursprünglich ausgegangen sind
bitte 38 Personen die diese
Rettungskräfte in den Hinterhalt gelockt
haben ja davon waren die allermeisten
unter 21
da müssen wir doch sagen das kann ja
auch eine Phase sein oder ich meine
nicht dass ich es deswegen toleriere das
ist eine andere Frage aber das ist eine
Phase ist also sozusagen ein ein
radikales bösartiges ich ausprobieren
das macht es nicht harmlos natürlich
auch ja es macht schlimm genug aber ich
sage mal wenn die gleichen Leute mit 40
noch die gleiche Wut im Bauch haben dann
würde es richtig gefährlich genau davon
gab es nicht wenigstens zwischen 17 und
23 ja dann würde man man sagen ist das
Problem etwas kleiner als wenn ich sagen
würde hier wird ein Hass gezüchtet der
für das halbe Leben erreicht das sind
Dinge die müsste man unterscheiden also
dass die die diese Rettungskräfte da in
die Hinterhalt gelockt haben ja also die
Verachtung Spinne diese Jugendlichen
Spinner ja
los Richard das finde ich reicht nicht
dass sie keine schwimmen unter 21 ist
und solche Dinge gemacht kann man im
Zweifel es war eher ein Spinner sein als
wenn man in unserem Alter sowas aber ist
man ein echt sowas macht ist man ein
durch und durch krimineller Sack aber
wenn man sowas nennt sich krimineller
Sack absolut ja aber man hat kein
Bewusstsein davon das ist der
Unterschied sicher komm überleg mal wie
du mit 18 19 warst da hast du da haben
wir doch angefangen über die Dinge
wirklich nachzudenken sorry tut mir leid
ja aber man hat auch viel Scheiß gemacht
über den man nicht zu Ende nach
Polizisten geschossen nein natürlich
nicht das meine ich doch es scheiß
machen ist das eine aber billige den
aufnehmen dass Menschen schwer verletzt
werden die nochmal da sind um anderen zu
helfen das ist eine andere Dimension ich
bin auf deiner Seite ich weiß nicht
unterscheide zwei Sachen ich halte das
für gefährliche Straftaten genau wie du
aber ich versuche mir zu erklären was
geht in den Köpfen von 18 19 und
20-jährigen ab die so ein Mist machen
und da denke ich dass das jetzt nicht
unbedingt zu Ende geplante Straftaten
von durch und durch kriminellen Naturen
sind sondern dass das auch Greifer sich
am Anfang gesagt hat da macht sich
jemand ein teuflischen Jungs ohne zu
merken dass das überhaupt kein Jux ist
sondern dass das gefährliche Straftaten
sind das ist ein bisschen mein Verdacht
es wäre was anderes wenn ich sage
dahinter steht eine Ideologie dahinter
steht religiöser Fanatismus und so
weiter aber dafür haben wir in diesem
Fall soweit ich das bisher weiß keine
indizieren
ja also kann man also nach dem Spaß an
bösartiger Randale doch im Mittelpunkt
zu stehen ich weiß es nicht also wenn
wenn du hörst dass das das ich meine es
gibt ja auch immer wieder die die große
Debatte auch für uns Medien immer wieder
schwierig ne also nennst du das
Herkunftsland oder nennst du es nicht
sagst du mit wem du es dazu tun hast
oder sagst du es nicht jetzt auch der
Antrag der CDU zu sagen okay von denen
mit deutscher Staatsbürgerschaft hätten
wir jetzt gerne mal die Vornamen das
empfinde ich auch als etwas wo ich sage
puh das ist
das ist grenzwertig jetzt mal das so
über über diese also grundsätzlich finde
ich es richtig und da bin ich gegen die
klassische Sichtweise der Linken dass
das gesagt wird die Linken haben
dafür ich bin dafür dass das gesagt wird
und zwar schon aus dem einfachen Grund
damit die AFD nicht sagt ja ist richtig
richtig
ja das wird offiziell verschleiert und
verheimlicht und das wird gedeckt und so
weiter und wir ermitteln das jetzt und
hier kriegen dann die Wahrheit raus so
wenn das also sowieso rausgefunden wird
dann kann man es auch gleich von
staatlicher Seite Aussagen ja du weißt
Vornamen Preis geben muss weiß ich nicht
so genau weil der Kölner Silvester nach
was ja eindeutig da waren auf der
Domplatte die an den Straftaten
beteiligt waren ja fast keine deutschen
aber also hier war der Falle ganz ganz
eindeutig viel eindeutiger als er hier
ist wir haben ja offenkundig ein Problem
können Silvester Nacht und da ist es
jetzt die die sozusagen die Verachtung
für den Start ganz generell wir haben
offenkundig ein Problem
mit jungen Männern die ein echt
problematisches Frauen- und Weltbild mit
sich rumtragen ohne Zweifel
die Frage ist die nach der Konsequenz
Richard was würdest du sagen jemand wenn
du jetzt hörst ein Drittel Syrer und
Afghanen
beides hochproblematische Länder
abschieben oder nicht
ja du stellst mir schwierige Fragen ich
glaube das müsste man doch nicht
pauschal beantworten also die Frage wäre
doch jetzt zum Einzelfall was wird
demjenigen über den wir hier reden zur
Last gelegt oder das irgendwo dabei war
oder dass er ganz konkret jemanden
verletzt aber jemand verletzt jemand
getötet jemand vergewaltigt oder ob ein
Handy geklaut hat das sind ja alles
unterschiedliche Dinge mal gucken wir
bei jedem biodeutschen ganz ganz genau
darauf hin und sagen da liegen
Lichtjahre zwischen uns richtig und die
Frage ist sind das Äußerste Gewalttaten
die da begangen waren oder davon redet
davon richtig also wäre gewaltiger
umzubringen tatsächlich eine
Vergewaltigung oder Körperverletzung
methodes folgen oder solche Dinge
ja da bin ich tendenziell für
Abschiebungen auch in ein
problematisches Land wie Afghanistan
tja
ich bin froh ich sag mal als erstes ich
bin froh dass ich das nicht so
entscheiden muss und B ist das ja eine
Entscheidung die letztlich die Justiz
Fällen muss oder meine noch mache ich ja
die Frage nach der Konsequenz ne
du buchtest die Leute ein und am
nächsten Tag sind sie wieder draußen und
dann beginnt diese Mühle und mühsame
Strafverfahren und so weiter und es
dauert ewig das heißt bis der die Folgen
seines Handelns zu spüren bekommt ist im
Zweifel so viel Zeit vergangen dass du
schon gar nicht mehr weißt was
eigentlich gemacht hat ja also wenn ein
Jahr dazu liegt dann wird im Kopf
jedenfalls nicht mehr der Engel Connex
hergestellt ne zwischen dem was man
getan hat und der Strafe dann denkt man
nur der blöde Staat will mich ärgern und
jetzt muss ich schon wieder da hin und
wieder
geklaut genau dieses Neuköllner Modell
Kirschen leider verstorbene Richterin ne
richtig und ähm ja vorgeschlagen hat
dass man diese Verfahren enorm verkürzt
hat unmittelbar ja und das unmittelbar
die spürbar ist das hat ja auch einen
hohen abschreckungscharakter für die
Kameraden ja genau wenn man sofort sieht
was passiert richtig ja also es ist
natürlich immer so eine komplizierte
juristische Frage wie stark kann man
sowas tatsächlich verkürzen ohne dass
der Rechtsstaat karnevalisiert wird aber
im Prinzip sind die schnellen Verfahren
und was wichtiges ja sozusagen
unmittelbare Reaktion darauf nur so
kannst du doch als Staat auch als wie
soll man sagen gelassen souverän stark
auftreten das doch das was du machen
musst so erleben die den Staat als
völlig schwach ich weiß noch ich habe
mal mit mit jemandem aus Berlin darüber
gesprochen auch in der Sendung der sagte
der ist heute Streetworker und und war
aber selbst mal völlig auf der schiefen
waren unterwegs
netter Mann der der sagte was in meiner
Jugend war das so ich ich habe dann
irgendwelchen Scheiß gebaut und dann bin
ich kurz festgenommen worden und dann
hatte die Berliner Polizei diesen tollen
Service die haben mich dann am nächsten
Morgen immer wieder nach Hause zu meinen
Eltern gefahren wieso habe ich die
wahrgenommen ja und sind ja dann häufig
auch Jugendliche die ihre Kindheit
vielleicht in Afghanistan oder in Syrien
verbracht haben natürlich ein anderer
Art von Staat kennengelernt haben in
Afghanistan überhaupt kein so ist
überhaupt kein funktionierenden Staat
gibt dafür aber ein irrsinniges Ausmaß
an Gewalt ja Warlords und so weiter ja
tausend ungeschriebene Gesetze an die
man sich halten muss und wo man härteste
körperliche Konsequenzen spüren muss und
in Syrien ja eine Diktatur ist richtig
und das ist das was man quasi in seinen
Knochen hat er noch was die Eltern
kennen und so weiter und dann kommt man
nach Deutschland und hat dann in
Relation das Gefühl dass man machen kann
was man will so aber auch hier müssen
wir dazu sagen ja 90% oder noch mehrere
die in dieses Land kommen die sehen das
anders ja die sind wunderbar integriert
in dieses Jahr und ärgern sich darüber
dass der Staat das zulässt das ist muss
man immer wieder sagen die wirklich ich
habe so viele meiner engsten Freundes
ist Marokkaner ist Arzt ja
liebe Grüße
der der sagt das auch sagt das ist
unglaublich warum warum lasst ihr euch
das gefallen verstehst nicht ja also die
schämen sich für ihre Landsleute weil
sie ja natürlich das Image
maßgeblich bestimmen die
verhaltensauffällig werden bestimmen das
Image ja die sich wunderbar angepasst
und integriert sind und stützen dieser
Gesellschaft sind bestimmen leider das
Image nicht weißt du was interessantes
hassen ein K7 ne den
wir in dieser Woche in der Sendung
hatten und den ich sehr schätze weil er
auch dann sehr sehr differenzierten
Blick drauf hat der sagt wir müssen
darüber reden wir können das nicht
einfach alles wegschweigen und sagen nee
das hat mit Herkunft und so weiter
nichts zu tun und der sagte dieser Tage
Ansatz und da habe ich aufgehört muss
man jeden aufnehmen der Asyl sagt
darüber darf man streiten wenn wir leben
nicht jeden auf der sagt
wenn wir jeden aufnehmen würden ja
asylsacht hätten wir noch sehr sehr viel
mehr Menschen ja aber jemand der ist an
die deutsche Grenze schafft und sagt ich
brauche Asyl dem Gewehren wir erstmals
das ist ja so das wird überprüft das
wird überprüft ja genau aber erstmal ist
er da und in aller Regel bleibt auch da
und er sagt was ich den Gedanken darüber
fand ich interessant er sagt ich kann
einerseits das Unbehagen darüber
verstehen die Aufnahme von Menschen in
Not an Bedingungen zu knüpfen
für interessant sagt aber auch ich
empfinde aber andererseits auch
Unbehagen Anhänger von Diktatoren und
Menschen mit autoritären Weltbild
aufzunehmen also wenn Leute kommen die
ganz offensichtlich mit den Taliban
sympathisieren ja eigentlich müsste das
alles relativ einfach die Antwort wäre
das müsste alles in aller Ruhe geprüft
werden so und da ist alle Ruhe in dem
Fall meistens nicht da und Bielefeld an
allen Ecken und Enden das Personal um
das in aller Gründlichkeit zu überprüfen
das kommt der Staat an seine Grenzen er
kann das nicht also das was er
eigentlich tun müsste kann er gar nicht
nicht mit dem Personal was er hat das
sind ja viel zu wenige Menschen die das
überprüfen ist ja alles viel zu
kompliziert
internationale Zusammenarbeit mit den
Ländern funktioniert nicht aus denen die
Menschen kommen
du weißt nicht ob der passt in der dir
vor zeigt seiner ist und so weiter und
so weiter sind wie eine wahnsinnig
komplizierte Problematik ist es ja aber
nichts ist so weniger werden wir
Antworten geben müssen wir werden
Antworten geben müssen weil sonst
irgendwann die Menschen in diesem Land
und dazu gehören auch ausdrücklich alle
mit Migrationshintergrund die empfinden
diesen Startern zunehmend als
dysfunktional und das ist ein echtes
Problem das ist ein riesiges Problem
also ein Staat der von seiner
Bevölkerung oder von sagen wir mal nicht
ganz unwesentlichen Anteilen der
Bevölkerung nicht mehr ernst genommen
wird er hat ein riesiges Problem
diese Sorge kann ich vollständig Teilen
okay also eine gut funktionierende
Demokratie Kennzeichen sich nicht
schlichtweg dadurch dass die Leute darin
wählen können weil wählen können die
Menschen in sehr sehr vielen Ländern in
dieser Welt ja das sind unglaublich
viele Länder in denen irgendwie gewählt
ja klar ja sondern eine Demokratie
beruht darauf dass man Vertrauen in ihre
Institutionen hat und dass dieses
Vertrauen von der Mehrheit der Menschen
auch tatsächlich gehackt wird das heißt
also ich muss Vertrauen dass es eine
funktionierende Justiz gibt eine
funktionierende Polizei eine
funktionierende Armee auf all diese
Dinge muss ich vertrauen können wenn ich
darauf nicht vertrauen kann und das
Vertrauen in den Staat verschwindet dann
irodiert jede Gesellschaft was
abschließend gefragt Richard was wir zu
sagen ich ich was ich sozusagen das
beste gegenrezept ich würde immer sagen
man muss wirklich einfordern dass
Schulen funktionieren das Bildung
funktioniert
die Antwort ist Bildung das stimmt aber
es ist leichter gesagt als getan wenn
man sich damit beschäftigt habe ich ja
mal ein dickes Buch über Bildung
geschrieben also die die Problematik ist
die Erfolge von Bildung die zeigen sich
dann auch so im Regelfall in der
Gesellschaft vielleicht 20 Jahre später
genau ja das ist ein sehr sehr langer
Prozess und jetzt könnte ich ein
bisschen sagen also wenn man wenn man
guckt wer in meiner Heimatstadt Solingen
heute Abitur macht wie hoch ist die
Quote derjenigen die
Migrationshintergrund haben und das mal
Vergleich mit der Zeit als ich Abitur
gemacht habe
wie viele Menschen Migrationshintergrund
hatte ich in meiner jugendstufe
vielleicht zwei und davon niemand aus
der Türkei oder aus dem muslimischen
Land
und das sieht heute alles ganz ganz
anders aus das heißt also ein sehr
erheblicher Teil der bildungsintegration
funktioniert genau aber er funktioniert
insgesamt bei Mädchen besser als bei
Jungs so und das Wesentliche passiert ja
im Grunde genommen im Kindergarten im
Kindergarten lernt man Integration
bestenfalls jedenfalls sollte man lernen
und man lernt Deutsch denn wenn man kein
Deutsch kann dann wird man von Anfang an
abgehängt sein hat seine
Frustrationserlebnisse und dann kann man
sich den Rest denken da muss man raus
genau ja
in Deutschland nicht schaffen
flächendeckende Sprachunterricht in
Kindergarten z.B zu machen und darüber
diskutieren wir seit Ewigkeiten ich kann
mich noch zurück erinnern an vor 15
Jahren als Guido Westerwelle davon
gesprochen hat ja dass jedes Kind in der
Schule ist eingeschult wird Deutsch
können sollte
und dass das damals überhaupt eine
Debatte über dieses Thema gab das ist
Leute gab nach dem Mottos kann man doch
keinen vorschreiben ist heute
unerklärlich geworden also auch damals
war meine Position schon natürlich ja
muss jedes Kind das in die Schule
eingeschult wird Deutsch können und eine
wichtige Voraussetzung dafür eins meiner
Lieblingsthemen ich habe in meinem Buch
über die Bildung eine
Kindergartenpflicht vorgeschlagen so das
wollte ich dich gerade fragen das ist
nämlich wichtig also Kindergartenpflicht
ist nichts undemokratisches ne da gibt
es in Frankreich und die Luxemburg und
so weiter auch eine Kindergartenpflicht
dass man mit drei in Kindergarten kommt
und damit diejenigen die aus
Elternhäusern kommen die mit diesem
stark vielleicht nicht allzu viel zu tun
haben durch die Kindergarten
sozialisationen Teil der Gesellschaft
werden und nicht mit sechs in die Schule
kommen kein Deutsch können und auch
sonst wenig Vorstellungen von dem Land
haben wie es funktioniert hinter dem sie
leben also schöner Schlusssatz Richard
ich danke dir wir hören uns nächste
Woche ja alles Gute tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]